- [Interviewer] All right.
Robert? - Mmm hmm.
- [Interviewer] Robert,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from New York, Harlem,
New York city, 116 2nd Avenue.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Yeah, for a little while
because my father used to beat up
on my mom all the time and stuff.
So as a kid, I used to
always put my sisters
in their room so they don't
have to go through it.
(groans) Every time he
would hit her and stuff
I would like try to get
in the middle and stuff
so he would hit me and stuff.
Then I will tell him,
mom, dad, why are you,
Papi, why are you hitting her?
You know?
And he wouldn't answer me.
"Get out of here", you know,
smack me and stuff like that,
you know, but he would lock her
in the room and started throw
ashtrays on her, you know?
And I always get in the front
of him and stuff, try to,
you know, stop it and stuff.
But I was just a little boy, you know.
I couldn't do much and stuff.
You know,
I couldn't understand why he
was hitting her all the time.
- [Interviewer] Your mom?
- Yeah, my mom and so,
and come to realize
after a whole lot of
years later, you know,
it was because he was jealous
of her career and stuff.
My mom came over here with, at age 18
from Puerto Rico, you know,
and made something to herself, you know.
She worked hard and she always told me:
"You want to be somebody
in life, get an education."
And she went to college and all that.
She made something of herself,
you know, she be good.
I'm always, always a
good person, but you know
Ooh, excuse me. (sniffles)
When I was about five years old and stuff,
I was molested from my babysitter,
(traffic passes) you know
cause my father was
always drunk, you know?
So it was like my mom would
have to pay somebody else
to watch us and stuff,
you know, after school.
(sighs heavily)
Excuse me. (engine revs)
Oh, man.
You know, but I was, I was
molested by my babysitter.
You know after that and my
mom couldn't take it no more,
and she, and we left, we left my father
in the apartment all by himself
(brakes squeal) and stuff.
You know, we had to escape
through the fire escape (brakes
squeal) to get away from him
'cause he wouldn't let us through,
out through the door, (brakes
squeal) the front door.
So we had to escape through a fire escape.
You know, I remember it well.
I had to take my sisters down one
by one and stuff and I'm a
little boy, but you know, I just
I did whatever when my
mom told me to, you know?
What little boy want to see
his mom get hit, you know?
You know, but anyway we
moved to another apartment
(sniffles softly) and my mom, you know,
she knew that I was going through a lot,
so she put me into sports
and stuff, you know
(sniffles) to try to
get me, get me, you know
my mind away from that
and stuff, you know?
And I, I became real
good at sports and stuff,
but, (traffic passes) I don't know.
I always had it.
I would try to hold everything inside
until I would explode,
you know? (horn honks)
And then come to find
out my oldest sister,
my father tried to rape
her on the roof, you know?
And I didn't know about this, you know?
His own brother beat the fuck out of him
when he found out what happened.
And so, you know, my mom took my sister
and sent her to Puerto Rico and stuff.
You know, 'til everything was cleared
out and stuff, you know.
I dunno whatever happened
about that case and stuff, you know?
But my own uncle man, beat the
hell out my father, you know?
And just like, man
tried to rape my sister?
What's wrong with you, you
know, but I don't get it, man.
You know?
And I always respected him, but I just,
I couldn't do what he wanted to do.
It wasn't no father, you know,
like I knew he was my father
but, it's like, I have no love and respect
for him because of what he
did and stuff, you know?
I don't want to be like that all my life.
I tried to like, don't
hit no women, you know.
I wouldn't do nothing like
that and stuff, you know.
It's, I don't want to be
nothing like him, you know?
But I started messing up.
You know, I started doing,
turning toward drugs and stuff.
You know, just doing stupid shit.
Crime, committing crimes
and stuff, you know?
So that way (traffic passes)
I'm not in my head all the time
'cause my head man, oh man,
it's something else, you know?
- [Interviewer] How
far'd you go in school?
- I went through to ninth
grade and I was supposed to go
to high school, but me
trying to be a player
or whatever you want
to call it, stupid ass,
you know, I started dating
cousins and all that,
and they chased me out of school
with bats and stuff, you know,
'cause I was dating the same
cousins and stuff, you know?
So I dropped out of school, you know
and my mom always said, "If
you're not going to school,
you gotta get a job."
You know?
So that's what I did.
I got a job, and I
started working, you know.
My mom was the one that
got me my first job
when I was seven years old,
working at the best fruit stand, you know,
that was beautiful.
You know, cause she
always told me, you know,
"I'll get you what you need,
but if you want something, you
gotta do that on your own."
And I respected that.
You know, my mom always
had good jobs, you know
'cause she had a college degree.
You know, she was a nurse, you know,
and from there she became a cop.
I was so proud of her.
Man, she came out on the
newspaper and the front page
and all that and the Puerto Rican parade.
It was beautiful, you know,
and I got like a hundred
newspapers and stuff, you know
with her picture on there.
You know, 'cause I was proud
of my mother, you know.
She always been like my mother
and my friend, my best friend, you know?
And she always told me
the truth, you know?
No matter what happens is to just call me
and I'll come get you,
and she was the only one
that ever kept her word.
Everybody else was just like,
they lied to me, you know?
So it's like, I grew up
with a lot of hatred,
you know, anger, I don't
know, (bird chirps)
just, I couldn't understand
it and stuff, you know,
but my mom always tried to like,
tried to put me in school and all that.
You know, I just recently,
like maybe four years ago,
(bird chirps)
I went back to school and I
got my GED diploma, you know?
And I dedicated that to my mom.
Cause she was always trying
to get me to, (engine revs)
you know, get my education and all that.
She said, "If you want
to be somebody in life,
you have to get an education."
You can always get a job and then that,
but if you want a career
and people respect you,
get an education, you know?
And I believe that, you know,
but I was so stupid, you know,
like always went into one ear
and out the other, you know,
(birds chirp) and now
it's like my baby sis,
my baby sister passed away from cancer.
That hurt me a whole lot.
I was always close to her, you know?
And I tried throwing my father
out the window, you know?
And if it wasn't for my
cousin, I would have succeeded.
You know, because it's
just, you know, my sister,
she died of cancer and you know, she had
she gave birth to my nephew and stuff,
and six months later they
found out that she had cancer
but it was too late (birds chirp)
to do anything about it and stuff.
It's already went to her
stomach and all that.
Man, it was hard to see my
sister go like that, you know?
But, I guess it's a reason for
everything in life, you know?
And it's like, oh man, (air
brakes hiss) ever since then,
if I just have been on one, I don't know.
I do good for a little while
(birds chirp) and then I get
into my head, and it's, I
messed everything up and stuff.
(horn honks) Every time I was doing good
and stuff like that, I always
find a reason to mess it up.
And I don't know why I keep
doing that, but it's like
I just started going to therapy and stuff
and I'm trying to get all these feelings
and emotions out of me and stuff,
'cause I still have all that inside of me,
and every time I think about it and I cry
and I have all this anger and stuff,
'cause I never let it out
and I always held
everything inside, you know?
And I don't want to take
it out on the wrong person
or do something stupid and get me
in jail for the rest of my life.
You know, I've been in and out of jail,
for the, like the last 30 years, man.
I'm tired of that.
I'm seriously tired. (birds chirp)
I just want to do
something to help people,
and you know, the last
time I was in jail was 2013
and I asked The Lord,
"Man, please help me stay out of jail."
"Help me to become a
good person and stuff."
I had no idea it was going
to get me a heart, you know?
I ain't never felt nothing in life
'cause I didn't want to, you know, I mean,
you know everything I
went through and stuff,
I was like, for what I'm doing this for?
For what reason and stuff, it's
just gonna end up the same?
You know, I didn't trust no man.
And my stepfather, he came into our life
like maybe two years
after we left my father
and I didn't even trust him and stuff.
And he was good.
He was good to us.
All he ever wanted, was a family, a son.
And so, cause he couldn't have no kids.
You know, (truck beeps)
and he was so proud to
say I'm his son, you know?
And since I didn't trust nobody and stuff,
I couldn't like, love
him the way I wanted to,
(brakes squeal) you know?
And he did a lot for us.
You know, but I never, I just
I don't know if I didn't appreciate it
or it just, I was just scared, you know?
(traffic passes loudly)
But I think about it
now, and I felt so bad,
for all the things I've
done to him, you know?
I mean, I've done, I hit him, you know?
I pushed, as a little boy I put
cigarette butts in his beer,
you know, but it's,
I guess I was trying to push him away,
so he don't hurt my mother, you know?
And it's like, man, and coming
out to think about it now,
all that man ever tried to do was love us.
You know what I mean?
It's like, and I was pushing 'em away.
I don't know for what reason.
I just, you know, and he
passed away from cancer too.
So then my mom passed away, of cancer.
A lot of people in my family passed away
from either cancer or
cirrhosis of the liver,
and stuff like that, you know?
I've been to a lot of funerals
and I'm just tired (bird
chirps) of going through it.
Then my last couple of
girlfriends, they ended up,
after I get with them, it's
like they will all die on me
or something.
I don't know why.
I already had,
I already had maybe, like
four girlfriends, you know?
It's like, I'm tired of it, man.
I try.
I mean, when my sister was in
the hospital dying of cancer,
I asked the Lord and said,
"Why are you taking her
for, she's so good?"
"Why don't you take me, you
know, I'm the one that's messed
up in my head and stuff."
I just, but I couldn't understand it.
I didn't understand, The
Lord, when The Lord wants you,
he gonna get you, you know?
And you have to believe in that, you know,
you have to believe in
something in life, you know?
So it's like, man, I'm
surprised, I'll be 52 next month,
and I,
I ain't think I'll make it to pass 25.
You know, because of the way I was living.
I didn't wanna live, you know?
Going through that in life, man, it's man,
it messes you up, you know?
And I'm trying to get back, you know?
I'm trying to be good.
You know, I don't do all the
things that I used to do,
like rob people and sell drugs, and,
I don't commit no crime,
not even jaywalking.
I'm too scared,
'cause I don't want to
go back to prison man.
You know, I'm tired of that, man.
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to be a bad person
but I didn't think he would
give me a heart, you know?
I actually cried today.
You know, I actually do things
for people without
expecting anything back.
You know, I don't know why,
that's his doing, and all I
asked was (traffic passes)
for me to get it, to stay
out of prison, that's all.
That's all I want, man, do good.
Help somebody.
You know, I didn't think
he would give me a heart
like this though.
I mean, I help everybody, even
though they steal from me,
and you know, just do bad
stuff and I'm like, I try to,
I'm learning how to forgive.
I'm not going to say that I do,
but I'm learning how to forgive
and stuff like that,
you know? (birds chirp)
And I just, man, I just
want to help people in life.
Man, that's all.
You know, because I've done
a lot of bad things too.
And so I didn't do what my father did
but I've done a lot of
others, stupid, stupid things.
You know?
I don't know.
(brakes squeal)
I'm by myself now, you know?
I dunno why stuff-
- [Interviewer] So drugs come
into your life at what age?
- About 16 years old.
You know, I didn't turn to
alcohol like all my uncles
and all that, they died
of cirrhosis of the liver.
I've been to a lot of funerals
and I've seen a lot of, you
know, people turn, you know
when you dyin' of cirrhosis
of the liver, you turn yellow.
You know, coughing up blood and all that.
I didn't pick that up, but
I picked up smoking weed,
doing cocaine, you know,
I tried heroin one time.
No, huh uh, I'm afraid of needles.
- [Interviewer] So your drug is crack?
- Oh yeah, crack cocaine.
I still smoke weed, you know.
I don't drink because
I'm too scared of it.
Plus it's nasty.
I'd rather drink soda, but um,
I'm trying to like stop it, you know?
I'll like, stay away
from it for a few days,
and then like something
happens, an incident happen.
I go right back to it.
I don't know why that is
but I am really trying
to stay away from it
and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] You're surrounded
by it here on skid row.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're surrounded
by it. (laughs lightly)
- Yeah, I know.
But I mean, I could say no
on stuff until I get hurt
because I don't know
how to deal with that.
I never dealt with that in
my life before, you know?
I always held everything
inside until I blow up.
You know, but I'm, I'm learning,
little by little and stuff.
So I tryin' to stay out of jail.
I've been out since 2013.
I'm doing good.
I ain't bothered nobody in a long time.
You know?
I don't sell no drugs.
I don't do nothing stupid man.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- I don't want to go back, huh?
- Not really, man.
You know, I'm too scared
to let anybody in.
You know?
They, my therapist telling me I have a lot
of trust issues and
stuff like that, I mean-
- [Interviewer] Is there
anyone you trust in your life?
- Yeah, my oldest sister,
Darlene, that's the one
that my father (air brakes
hiss) tried to rape,
(engine idles) my, Darlene and stuff.
That's the only, I call.
That's the only phone
number I know by heart.
You know, I'll call home. (engine revs)
And I talked to her when
I'm feeling down and stuff.
Last time I spoke to her
I couldn't understand why
I was crying and stuff.
She told me because you feeling stuff now.
You finally letting you know,
your feelings show now and stuff.
You never did that before,
(birds chirp) but I'm trying now.
She wants me to settle down,
get married and all that,
but I'm too scared.
I'm too scared.
I don't want to be like
my father. (birds chirp)
You know?
I don't know if, what she says
you got to trust somebody
sometime. (brakes squeal)
But (engine revs) I guess
maybe I will someday.
I just, I don't know when,
(bird chirps) whenever.
I guess whenever, they
say God give you things,
when he feels you, when
you're ready for it and stuff,
so I'm still waitin', you know?
I still help people, even,
even though I know they
stealing from me and stuff,
I still help people and stuff.
I ain't never done that
before in my life, man.
I will get you if you
take something from me.
Now it's, I forgiving
them and I don't know why.
Just was never me before,
but he got something to do
with it and stuff, you know?
(birds chirp) - [Interviewer] Yep.
What's the most important
lesson you've learned,
in your life?
- Express your feelings.
Talk about it.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- Express your feelings.
Talk about it.
Learn how to talk about it, man.
'Cause if you don't, it will hurt you.
You'll always live life
with anger in your heart.
And I don't want to live like that, man.
The only capable of time
you can hurt somebody,
without even wanting to, you know?
I have seizures all my life,
and from time to time, I go
into a seizure and stuff, but
at least I'm not falling on
my face no more and stuff.
You know, waking up,
stuck to the floor with all
the blood coming out, you know?
But right now I really don't
know what to do with my life.
You know?
All I learned that I don't
want to go back to prison.
I don't want to hit no woman, you know?
I would love to trust somebody.
It's hard though.
It is hard.
That's a valuable lesson, man.
Learn how to trust
somebody. (traffic passes)
You know?
- [Robert] So it's just, I live
I try to live my life
one day at a time, man.
Try not to break no laws.
Try not to do nothing wrong,
and learn how to forgive.
(traffic passes)
- [Interviewer] All right, Robert.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- No problem.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with the therapy
and everything else you're doing.
- I hope so.
I hope it works.
I am changing.
I know I am.
And so, you know, cause I,
this was never me before.
You know?
But if feels good though.
I mean people actually come
up to talk to me and stuff.
Before it was a lot of people,
they would see the anger
and stuff, they'll be too scared
to say hello or anything, you know?
Now they say hi.
That's a start.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Robert] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Perfect.
Thank you. (birds chirp)